they are a las vegas bass based rock
band that are generating lots of talk
for their modern and heavier rock sound
and you can check them out now as they
start up their new residency at the
barber shop cuts and cocktails at the
cosmopolitan welcome ro laurent who's
not here we still want to give him some
love larry jason and nels also known as
velvet chains welcome guys
back on the show
and you guys
just got a residency i mean how cool is
that
super exciting we're beyond uh
having fun with this thing and and super
happy to be at the barber shop yeah the
costume now how did you how did you get
this residency what happened we won a
battle of the bands i don't think the
other bands were prepared we showed up
with weapons and
[Laughter]
you guys really took it seriously
yeah all the bands there were great and
we just happened to
just get the votes i mean what a great
place to get a residency if you've never
been to the barber shop it's a little
it's it's a hidden
speakeasy behind an actual barber shop
now tell us a little bit about
the bar and how it's set up yeah so you
walk into the barber shop and it looks
just like any other barber's shop right
there's a couple chairs you can get your
beard trimmed whatever you want but then
suddenly you keep walking and you head a
little bit towards the back there's a
secret door you got a knock some dude
looks out through the little thing they
let you in and you walk into this pretty
big speak easy beautiful bar
beautiful setup nice stage couches
lighting everything's just really really
cool spot you just would never know it's
there it's such an intimate setting and
you guys you get to be residents here
but other big names have also performed
there can you tell us about some of the
names that you've seen on stage there
before we've a couple of weekends ago we
weren't the ones playing we weren't one
of the bads but bruno mars popped up on
stage i know mgk has been on that stage
too i mean the list goes on but
yeah
you never know you never know what night
you could be there some massive
celebrity will get up there tell us a
little bit about your sound and what you
guys bring to the stage
um well we're
we're like a hard rock band we do an
original project as well that's kind of
our main thing but when you're you know
at the barber shop
you want to play songs that people know
and that they love and everything and we
just always tend to you know kind of
fall into that heavy rock and roll you
know category so we do a lot of uh
you know
stuff like allison chains pearl jam um
you know sound garden a lot of a lot of
older you know early 90s or late 90s
2000 type of hard rock that is the sound
that i think that we need for sure you
guys are amazing congratulations on the
residency cannot wait to see them oh you
got to check it out at the barber shop
over at the cosmopolitan thanks you guys
thank you thank you